Hey guys,
jared again.
Today we're talking about your favorite
little town in Colorado.
Yup.
South Park for the past three seasons.
The show's ditched at signature
standalone episodes and embrace season
long serialization and it's largely been
awesome.
Season 19 brilliantly blended themes of
pc culture advertising and
gentrification over a multi episode arc.
And most recently season 20 kicked off
with an even more ambitious storyline
that juggled the presidential election,
member berries,
a militant feminist Hartman,
a girl hating Dick flashing butters,
and a whole lot of internet trolling.
It all seem to be leading up to some
epic conclusion.
And then everything just fizzles out
into confusion convolution and only they
just blew up the internet.
So why did season 20 leave us feeling
all itchy and uncertain like a fourth
grade school wide outbreak of Lice had
just surface?
Well,
we have an idea and it all has to do
with Matt and trey secret sauce that
makes South Park's writing.
So good.
Welcome to this wisecrack condition on
South Park.
Season 20 what went wrong?
And as always,
spoilers ahead.
Watching south park feels like peering
inside the mind of the world's funniest
stoner.
It's unpredictable,
imaginative,
and completely unhinged in the best way
possible.
But make no mistake,
there's a strict order to the madness.
The show is constructed with one rigid
plotline rule.
We found out this really simple rule
that maybe you guys have all heard
before.
We can take these beats,
which are basically the beats of your
outline and if the words and then belong
between those beats,
you're
for instance,
here's a three plot storyline about
stick figure.
John John Adopts a stray dog and then
John wins the lottery and then John
becomes a scientologists.
John's story has a sucky narrative
because there is no cause and effect.
You could rearrange each action into any
order and it would remain a random
series of events in the life of a
lottery winning dog,
rescuing intro level scientologists.
So what makes good southpark approved
writing and whenever you can replace
your andwith,
buts or therefores,
it makes for better,
right?
Take South Park's famous Mormon episode
and annoyingly perfect Mormon kid moves
to town.
Therefore heat pisses everyone off.
Therefore stand decides to kick his ass,
but the kid is so nice that he tell
standing,
go ahead and beat him up.
Therefore,
Stan doesn't beat him up and said he
agrees to go to the kid's house for
dinner.
Notice how each action that begins with
therefore or but indicates a consequence
or reaction to the previous action.
Every pot point matters,
which is why the show never loses
momentum.
Okay,
so that's south park's golden rule,
but before we dive into what went wrong
with season 20 it's time to talk about
the orange tinted elephant in the room.
Yup.
The president of the United States stone
in Parker had been upfront about the
fact that like 99% of the pollsters,
they expected Turd Sandwich to win the
election and plan the series around that
outcome.
They had to do desperate minute read
rights in order to Aaron episode the day
after the election,
so not ideal.
As soon as giant Douche,
Mr.
Garrison wins the election,
the show starts breaking the creator's
core rules and getting them all put Dab
as seen in the two main plotlines member
berries and trolling.
Let's map out the member berries.
Plotline randy tries member barry's
false into eight and install jic
transcend things.
Get a little dark room.
I ran excel model not full times.
Therefore,
Randy realizes member berries are
dangerous,
brainwashing germs with the what's going
on with these member berries.
Meanwhile,
Mr.
Garrison along with his vp,
Caitlyn Jenner is leading in the polls,
but he realizes he doesn't have a plan
to carry out his campaign promises and
we'll look like a jackass if he wins.
What the hell do I do?
If I win,
I won't be able to do what I promised.
Therefore,
Mr.
Garrison spends the first half of the
series trying to sabotage his campaign
so hillary will win.
I don't know what the I'm doing.
I've got to come clean.
I,
I had no idea I would get this far,
but the fact of the matter is I should
not be president,
but his voters catch on and demand an
explanation.
Therefore,
Randy tells garrison the truth about his
popularity.
When the world is changing so fast,
it makes us yearn for the old ways.
When life seemed simpler,
but it doesn't mean those old ideas are
good for us now.
Therefore,
the two of them set out to destroy
member berries,
but quickly realized that these little
guys just won't die.
Therefore,
randy convinces Mr Carish to give a
heartfelt speech denouncing nostalgia on
November 8th you must vote against me
and show the world that you didn't think
the new star wars was all that good.
And there you have it.
A perfect half season set up.
Ray Hilary victory that follows the
golden rule of southpark storytelling.
Except newsflash,
hilary lost.
Suddenly they have to justify garrison
surprising when and that's when things
get messy.
Now,
south park has to improvise it's way
through the rest of the season and the
writers start to break their own
storytelling rules.
We go from a strictly but or therefore
based plot,
tweet,
big cluster of and bed starting with.
And then Mr.
Garrison winds anyway out of nowhere.
And then Kaitlin Barfs,
reinfecting,
Mr.
Garrison and randy with member berries.
So Randy and garrison trip out on the
stall.
Jah,
forget their quest to destroy member
berries and generally get stoked on
garrison's victory.
This presses the rewind button on the
plot,
watching them unlearn the perils of the
storage.
It is literally narrative back pedaling.
Also,
you have this nagging feeling that it
should take more than a bit of Berry
flavored nostalgia to explain garrison
split second transformation from
terrified self sabotaging presidential
candidate to the cocky leader of the
free world there today on there whose
hair?
It's the president of the United States.
From here,
the member barry storyline just
generally gets muddled.
At the beginning of the season,
they had a clear purpose to set up a
physical embodiment of the toxic
nostalgia that will eventually be
overcome like the human adds in the
earlier season.
They start out as lazy,
intoxicating berries and then they
magically turned into a weird vomit
inducing virus and then they stop by at
1920s nightclub in a brief side story
that seems quickly forgotten and then we
find out they're Nazis.
Mama Stan Jubril's not nurse to your
base.
Real old lines people line a maybe that
got our men being
also pals with Vladimir Putin and by the
end they're ultimately looking like a
tiny fruit militia.
Ultimately,
the show doesn't offer any justification
for the member berries transformation.
Instead we get a random progression of
events that build without any apparent
logic and that's just not the south park
emo.
Now onto another sub plot that got
tangled up by a trump win trolling for
most of the season.
We watched Kyle's Dad Gerald living his
best life as the wine.
Oh trolls skank hunt 42 this initially
conforms with the South Park philosophy
of story structure.
Gerald's trolling angers the Danes.
Therefore the Danes threatened to
release everyone's Internet history,
sending Gerald Cartman South Park and
the world into a panic.
Enter Hillary Clinton who's confidence
she's about to win the presidency,
but she finds out trolled trace might
leak her online activities.
Therefore she needs who is gang hunt 42
we believe he's the only one who can
save you then crap.
She loses the election and again,
the narrative structure starts to
crumble without her presidency to
defend.
Clinton doesn't have any real reason to
recruit Gerald's slash skank hunt 42 and
then confusingly Clinton recruits him
anyway with a vague mission.
He needs to infiltrate troll trace to
protect US secrets.
We want to send someone into Denmark
undercover and steal their technology.
This entire scene of Hillary meeting
Gerald below the bridge feel super weird
and disjointed,
almost like it's from an alternate
reality.
That's because it probably was recycled
material from the original.
If Hillary had one version of the
episode,
it's certainly what fit the south park
role of storytelling.
A newly elected hillary is afraid of
having compromising emails released by
troll trace.
Therefore,
she recruits Gerald to take down the
dates.
Gerald wants to stop troll trace from
revealing his secret identity anyway.
Therefore,
he agrees to go and delete the evidence
and save both of them from exposure.
But in this strange new president
garrison run world that can't fly.
So in a desperate attempt to salvage the
plotline,
the show reveals that Clinton's claim
was merely a ruse and she's actually
just helping the Danes kidnap American
trolls in exchange for the protection of
her email.
And then oops,
turns out they're just trolling the
American trolls they capture and then
this top Danish guy wasn't trying to
punish the trolls.
He's also just a giant troll trolling
the world for the loans and also he's
not even in Danish.
Did your brain just melt?
If so,
it's probably because South Park
abandoned its most basic narrative
premise.
None of the events in the trolling
narrative actually build off previous
actions.
They're just a seemingly random,
increasingly complicated laundry list of
plot points.
The show writers openly complained about
the narrative hold they dug for
themselves.
Come on,
this is South Park.
What's happened?
You less?
We used to have a challenging deal with
it.
They move onto the next one.
Now we've just been dealing with
trolling of Internet stuff over and over
week after week and I don't know about
you,
but I get pretty sick of it.
It almost feels like the Danish guys
announcement that he's just trolling the
world is a last ditch effort to rescue
the narrative.
Maybe this is like the new post funny
era of satire.
Just like Mr.
Garrison when he's drunk on member
berries,
a completely nihilistic troll doesn't
need plot consistency.
From there,
the writers need to wrap up a few
incompletes storylines,
most notably the risks cartman and
Gerald face from having their internet
history reveal so they commit plot Hari
Cari,
by blowing everything up.
That's right.
Everybody from Kyle's little brother Ike
to the top generals at the Pentagon
collaborate to take down the Internet
with a massive blitz of trolling and a
little help from Elon Musk space x
program.
By blowing up the internet and deleting
everybody's ugly a secrets,
they also destroy the cause and effect
relationship that isn't building up all
season instead of a satisfying
conclusion where things get resolved,
audiences just get a big old psych.
We're blowing everything up.
Before that,
the season had done such a good job of
analyzing the way the Internet has
fragmented our public and private
selves.
How this sense of privacy has given us
all the ability to behave like assholes
without the people we love ever having
to find out.
This was all building up to a really
promising conclusion,
but we never got it.
The show also brilliantly skewers the
outrage cycles that dominate Internet
culture as trolls expertly push our
buttons.
This kind of simmering outrage actually
seems like a more interesting
explanation for Mr Garrison's victory.
Then member berries,
the show never develops this idea aside
from giving it one quick shout out
during the finale tribers axiom,
trevor's axiom is a well known equation
in online trolling.
It's a way in which one person can
create a massive reaction on the
Internet all bringing up the worst in
humanity.
That sort of sounds like how I got
elected because Matt and Trey Thought
Hillary would win.
They spent the first half of the season
teasing the perils of having your
internet history exposed,
but since trump won hillary's emails
exposing her are no longer as relevant
as say the outrage cycles on social
media.
So what might season 20 of south park
have looked like in a parallel universe
where the Turd sandwich triumphs?
Haven't you seen the polls?
It's president elect senators or
according to a deadline interview with
stone and Parker viewers.
Got a sneak peek in the postelection
episode.
Bill Clinton and bill cosby joined
forces to announce their new South Park
is gentleman's club and obvious hangover
from me if Hillary,
one version of the episode later Bill
Confides in butters that the club was
actually a place for men to hide because
trust me,
my wife is a crazy bitch.
She and all the other women in the world
are about to get payback and we are all
completely,
Parker says that in the alternate
reality season 20 they would have
focused on bill settling into his new
role as the apparently terrified first
gentlemen of the u s it would have been
a fitting way to escalate the battle of
the sexes already underway at South Park
Elementary.
It also would have given a lot more
pointing seat to Carmen's newly inspired
fear of his girlfriend Heidi,
who he suspects is trying to destroy him
instead.
The first gentleman's club is
understandably abandoned.
So what does the future hold for South
Park?
Well,
the creators warrant being subtle when
they called the last episode of season
20 the end of civilization as we know
it,
if they're really leaving serialization
behind,
let's kind of a bummer because as messy
as season 20 was,
there was a lot of promise and in our
humble opinion,
they did some of their best work at the
decade in seasons 18 and 19 why let a
silly election between a giant Douche in
a Turd Sandwich ruin all that?
So what did you guys think is he's in 20
let us know what you think in the
comments.
Thanks for watching guys.
He thanks for watching wise crack.
If you can't get enough south park,
we're starting an all new South Park
podcast next week called respect our
authority.
We're actually a week behind because I
got sick this week,
but next week will be all in.
You can click here to subscribe early or
check out the description for the link.
All right.
Screw you guys.
I'm going home.
Catch you all next time.